and org slash cities tour
welcome to the to the National Museum of
mathematics and to a very special event
and I think we're all delighted that the
museum is putting on this event tonight
and even more delighted that they're
doing it with the support of the
mathematical Association of America
which is helping out tonight and in
particular loaned us James Tanton
tonight whom I will introduce in a
minute my name is John Ewing I'm the
president of math for America and I am a
mathematician just this was not meant to
be an AAA meeting by the way now every
professional mathematician knows that
mathematicians and their subject have a
certain reputation a world-famous
mathematician is walking in the
countryside one day when he comes upon a
huge flock of sheep and being a
world-famous mathematician goes up to
the shepherd and makes a proposition a
hundred dollars against one of your
sheep that I can tell you instantly how
many sheep are in the flock the Shepherd
knowing that they're an awful lot of
sheep says ok I'll try it
mathematician looks around and says
there are 937 sheep in this flock the
Shepherd says incredible that's
absolutely incredible
the mathematician picks up an animal
throws it around his shoulders and
begins to walk away the Shepherd runs
after him wait wait he says double or
nothing I can tell you exactly what your
profession is now the mathematician
thinks this is unlikely so says sure go
ahead the Shepherd says you are a
world-famous mathematician incredible
says mathematician how could you
possibly know well says the shepherd
put down my dog and I'll tell you this
reputation is not new in 1914 William D
Lewis the principal of William Penn High
School in Philadelphia wrote about
democratizing education and he focused
on high school mathematics my objection
he wrote to the traditional requirements
in mathematics is largely empirical I
have seen so many pupils driven out of
school by work which could not have any
practical advantage to them and I have
watched so many classes in guessing
under the caption of algebra that I have
come to believe that we ought to
discriminate as carefully as possible
between those pupils who really need the
advanced mathematics and those who will
find other work more profitable 19:14
what mathematics we teach in our schools
especially our high schools has been
debated for the past century often with
an eye toward democratization and
opportunities for students indeed much
longer than a century you may be unaware
that arithmetic was not taught in
elementary school in the colonial period
spelling reading and writing constituted
the curriculum at that time arithmetic
was known as vulgar arithmetic was
needed and when it was needed it was
learned in the job by the early 20th
century algebra and geometry were part
of the curriculum in nearly every high
school in the country but the graduation
rate in 1900 was 8% 8% and as graduation
rates climbed over the coming decades
the role of mathematics became a
contentious issue almost everywhere
mathematics was then as it continues to
be now the most difficult of subjects
for many students the debate culminated
at the end of the 20th century with
three
talkative and quite exceptional essays
written by underwood dudley a
mathematics professor at DePaul
University with the titles why math is
mathematics necessary and what is
mathematics for to the dismay of many
mathematicians woody argued that there
were many good reasons to teach
mathematics but utility wasn't one of
them almost all jobs he wrote required
no knowledge of algebra and geometry at
all he went on where algebra necessary
for 75% of all jobs our algebra
textbooks would be filled with
on-the-job problems since examples would
be so plentiful this is clearly not the
case
the math mystery by Andrew hacker which
is the catalyst for tonight's discussion
is in many ways the child of this
century long debate as well as woody
Dudley's essays although I will say that
the two authors reached very different
conclusions is high school mathematics
serving society what mathematics should
be taught how should it be taught and
why should it be taught these are hard
questions and I believe that finding
answers to hard questions is best done
in open and public discussion that's why
we're here tonight our two speakers this
evening are Andrew hacker and James
tantric and you'll be glad to know I've
reached the point where I introduced
them
andrew hacker is a professor of
political science at Queens College in
the City University of New York where in
addition to teaching political science
he has taught experimental course in
experimental course in mathematics
literacy he was an undergraduate at
Amherst College and received his PhD
from Princeton University he taught at
Cornell from 1955 until the early 1970s
and since then he has been on the
faculty of Queens College he is the
author of 10 books and a sample of the
titles suggest their reach to nations
black and white separate hostile and
unequal mismatch the growing gulf
between women and men higher education I
have to ask the question there how
colleges are wasting our money and
failing our kids and what we can do
about it in 1912 into in 2012 he
published an op-ed in the New York Times
entitled is algebra necessary which led
to his most recent book the math myth
and other stem delusions setting the
stage for tonight's discussion whether
or not you agree with the substance of
these books I am sure you will all agree
that the titles are every one of them
exceedingly clever
James Tanton grew up in Adelaide
Australia and when he speaks
tonight you may detect that he is not a
native of New York he received his
undergraduate degree in mathematics at
Adelaide University and came to the u.s.
in 1988 where he received his PhD in
mathematics also from Princeton
University after teaching at st. Mary's
College in Maryland in exceptional
liberal arts college I might add he
followed his wife to Boston where he
soon turned his attention to the general
state of k-12 mathematics
eventually he found himself at a private
school in Southborough st. more in
Southborough st. marks where he founded
the st. Mark's Institute of mathematics
then on to Washington DC where he served
as the mathematical Association of
America's visiting mathematician and
then their mathematician in residence
James consults with schools all across
the globe on the teaching of middle
school and high school mathematics he is
also the author of a number of books
solved this mathematics activities for
students and clubs mathematics galore
and is also the author of two wordless
puzzle books without words and more
without words both of which I'm told are
being presently translated into Serbian
I had offered to complete the
translation forum tonight but James is
also part of the global math project
with a goal of initiating a fundamental
change in the way we perceive and enjoy
mathematics tonight's presentation will
be divided into six segments two
15-minute presentations by each of our
speakers to lay out the case - eight
minutes Ponce's from each and then
questions and answers from the audience
well actually the questions are from the
audience and presumably the answers are
from a speaker followed by a short time
for people to come up and talk
individually with the speakers tonight
my job tonight is to keep us on schedule
and I will do so with ruthless resolve
here so I would like professor hacker to
begin tonight's presentation
[Applause]
okay thank you John and it is pleasure
to be here I may be the only non
mathematician in the house but that's
the reason I'm here I will say at this
point it is not my intention even if you
are math teachers to put you out of
business
I think yours is a grand and glorious
calling there are a total at last count
because I'm a statistician two hundred
seventeen thousand five hundred eighty
four teachers of mathematics in this
country it's a sturdy profession I don't
think it has anything to fear from me
now I'm a political scientist and the
chief job of political scientist is to
analyze policy particularly governmental
policy and even more particularly
governmental policies which require
everyone to do a certain thing very
simply if you're going to drive a car
you have to pass a test the government
says that we can now have a child I back
there the child has to be vaccinated we
understand that what interested me
therefore is a political scientist is in
effect of governmental policy that we
have which is that every single young
person in this country will be required
required to take a full sequence of
mathematics starting right with algebra
geometry precalculus and for many the
ideal is to have everybody study
calculus and my simple reason for being
and simple reason for writing my book
can be summed up in one word I
understand we have some visual aids here
all right I only learned this last
minute so I brought one of my own my
Apple at that
thank you and you may keep that up while
I'm talking okay we currently have
another statistic four million sixteen
year olds and the goal is to have every
single little bone enroll enrolled in
algebra two we have coming up the common
core and the common core is by the way
the common core is for everybody they
say career and college-ready but
everybody has to pass the Common Core
tests and our tests which are going to
be conducted nationally and algebra two
is going to be there well we're going to
be in for some problems we already have
some the math requirement the math
hurdle of you life takes a tremendous
toll every year we rank in the United
States very low among developed
countries about 20th out of 28 in the
number of our young people who finish
high school yes
our high school dropout rate is 20% one
out of every five young people you see
or older people in the street has failed
to finish high school
the major academic reason for that is
failure failing a math class I know
there are the reasons prism pregnancy
but the academic reason is we don't keep
exactly exact figures on this but Joe
Boulder Boulder whose book work you may
know has been quoted that a majority of
students eventually fail one or another
math course now is this because they're
indolent because they're stupid or is it
because we're asking something of
everyone that we really shouldn't be
requiring universally
one avec la don't graduate from high
school of those who graduate from high
school and go on to college
forty-three percent do not graduate it's
actually closer to forty five percent
yes this is one of the highest college
dropout rates in the advanced world we
have more colleges per capita but we
have fewer people finishing college why
because colleges mindlessly require
mathematics of everybody even if you're
going to major in poetry modern dance
interior design you still have to pass
an algebra test to get on board now we
have a fantastic talent loss here we're
shooting ourselves in the foot people
who would be really very skilled
talented as all sorts of fields are not
being allowed to proceed or even at the
junior college somebody who wants a
associate degree certificate in
cosmetology you know in you know in
industrial design
no no not industrial design let's say
commercial art you know even they have
to pass a math test and as a result our
attrition rate of Community College is
just Savage something else too we hear
reports acting that will report just
about years ago saying forty three
percent of people taking act that's the
test the colleges are not college ready
music goodness
forty three percent taking act the
college tests are not college ready you
know why because college ready requires
advanced mathematics for everybody and
as a result some very good students who
might be in my college class won't be
there because of this requirement now my
book is called the math myth and in fact
as more and more I studied for this
happen here the more discovered that
people who are entrenched on plant wheat
kind here
entrenched in a certain profession
occupation vocation will little
literally say anything to defend the
status quo from which they benefit this
can be true of police officers could be
told that and I discovered so much of
what were being told about man is sheer
myth for example there's a 62% figure he
have something called the American
diploma project completed they Mountain
said within a decade from now 62% of all
occupations will need algebra well as
Woody but you know underwood dudley that
years ago this is certainly a minute at
most five percent of occupations need
algebra bug and I respect those in the
course of writing my book I went down to
Marietta Georgia where I interviewed
aeronautical engineers of lucky and I
was just blown away by the way they use
calculus to study the ice on wings know
if they're fantastic things I've learned
about ice ice in a commodious is
different from ice in the Andes I don't
go on to it but you certainly might need
mathematics and Wall Street York wants
as they're called will use calculus all
the time to study risks payoffs and the
rest but not 62% a test 5% which is the
question if only going to talk in
occupational terms why the other 95 have
to take it I don't want to go too much
into the question the story because a
story to stem story we all know it's 10
means that there's a shortage of people
with stem qualifications in fact of
people who have degrees in STEM subjects
ste and less than half
only slightly a little bit more than a
third are working in stem occupations
now we actually have an oversupply of
people with still stem qualifications
we're totally better watch out in a
global competition because Korea China
Singapore on drums are far ahead of us
in mathematics it's true their students
score in the stratosphere on the
international map test you know the Pisa
tests and others they'll say dentist you
they score high because they work 23
hours a day you know the biggest illness
among young people in Korea the
pediatricians replied articles on this
is sleep deprivation they were 23 hours
a day if I want to say this in the best
way if the international competitions
are on chess or crossword puzzles the
Chinese and the Koreans would score up
there too
so the big challenge is not more math
for us but getting our kids we work 23
hours and I don't couldn't advise that
there's the whole question of whether
always rates with a math sharpens our
minds
I agree that studying math and really
doing well at it sharpens your mind for
dealing with mathematics that's for sure
there is no evidence whatever that
mastering mathematics makes you a jille
adept excel in other fields
there's none whatever I did is in my
book a short test of my own at Queens
College course I couldn't find any
evidence I took the math scores of our
incoming freshmen I took all the
freshmen who took an introductory
history course I plotted the math scores
no high-low versus the history scores
history use reasoning ability weighing
evidence guess what the correlation was
zero to be high on that bomb out in
history vice versa math does not help
you in other fields and that's just
another myth now
there certainly and I'm not sure I want
to call to submit there is the view for
example Keith Devlin who's a
mathematician I really respect I keep
his book like by the numbers on my
bedside it's one of the best books I've
read I'm showing a lay person what
mathematics really is and he closes the
book doesn't process the book is why
offenses he believes that mathematics is
that one of the greatest creations of
the human mind perhaps even the greatest
well hey I'll go along with that I
simply ask oh by the way is mathematics
something we created versus something
that we discovered could it be that
mathematics is out there created by
nature that she created the calculus we
courtesy as Isaac Newton had to discover
it it's like PI for example we didn't
create god but we had to find it and
show how it's used but all events what
I'm saying is I would really love for
everybody to appreciate mathematics its
glories its goals but this isn't being
done by making people slug through
polynomials year after year I would love
to have math teachers take off time and
treat mathematics as a live the Lord so
all of us that know the buicks beauty in
the poetry in mathematics there's also
the view that mathematics is objective
which is to say there's one right answer
you don't have to worry about opinions
subjectivity you know bias things like
that well this may well be true but
there's something else going on
mathematics has built-in biases of its
own not so much the subject but the way
we assess it and evaluate it one thing
we know I would Chaplin ago called
gender gaps in mathematics
girls and young women actually get
higher grades in math courses than the
guys do they do we have enough studies
across the board to show that ACT and
SAT both know that the girls get higher
grades but when it comes to the test ACT
SAT and then PSAT and a time it's going
to be coming for the men of always ahead
I would really ask you as mathematicians
to find some way of having tests because
we're going to continue to test people
that give the girls in the young woman a
chance to show what they really know for
the last half century girls have been 30
points behind boys on the SAT and by the
way you know that that has consequences
one consequence is the National Merit
Scholarships I I went into this the
National Merit Scholarships you know
what they do not give a gender breakdown
of their winners they refuse to do it
they hide that information you know what
because 53 percent a lot of the numbers
person 53 percent of the people who
enter the National Merit competition for
girls but boys end up getting 53 percent
of the awards
why because they score 30 points hotter
well PSAT is it for grading system then
the girls do on these tests the same
thing is going to happen with a common
core and this is one reason why girls
find it harder to get into Ivy League
schools because I believe schools
require 700 before we open your
application on mathematics both math and
durable it's seven hundred two-thirds of
those seven hundred and above avoids so
as a result Stanford Yale for example
our majority men why it goes of the math
barrier now girls are doing okay in your
classes but please I need some advice
the country does on how to gear
so they indicate what they know now math
of course we're told requires I have my
watch here do I have 30 seconds more 6
ok
ok I think my last comment here is do I
propose to abolish algebra no of course
but I do want to see other options and
alternatives instead of the full
sequence for everybody a 10th grade we
can work this out with begin to offer
options like I'm afraid I'm biased here
what I teach I teach a class at my
college in the math department holiness
called numeracy 101 which is about
citizen statistics you know not
high-powered academics citizen
statistics how to read a corporate
before how to look at the federal budget
it doesn't require any math all requires
is adults arithmetic and I don't think
we have to be ashamed of that at all
and now James Canton alright well thank
you Matt for hosting this evening this
is this is a real honor and a real treat
for the nation have this conversation
and thank you dr. Hecker for raising
this interest this is a really important
conversation having a national concern
very much appreciate you bring into the
world it really is absolutely vital that
we really reconsider and reassess the
state of mathematics education our
nation's next generations over and over
again and a lot of math school is
happening and you put that in your
pocket won't matter what isn't happening
and less is a cupboard upon us to expand
that good even further and thank you
becoming a lot today in those hopefully
viewing a video afterwards so your
interest in this topic and for your work
to probably understand current matters
and concerns and it's truly wonderful
that we adults we parents are personally
empowered to check facts double check
true to ourselves and personally assess
the validity of claims made that come
away in the media in the Internet and a
general conversation so that is we are
brave enough to ask how do we know what
we know and not succumb to just general
impression and general commentary alone
now I actually very much enjoyed reading
dr. Harris book the math but I came away
from with an interpretation that many
might find somewhat surprising I think
dr. Charcot
is actually arguing strongly very
strongly for the Common Core State
Standards and mathematics is beautifully
captured sets of deep concerns and
Morrison public perceptions that date
back before the conception of the Common
Core and all service mighty strong
warnings about how not to implement the
Common Core State Standards like me
dr. hacker doesn't want us
implementation to fall into old traps
resorting to rote formulaic teaching
resorting to heavy-handed speed testing
putting mechanistic mechanistic work are
doing above number facility and
quantitative literacy and above all
letting the human discussion experience
of mathematics be be pushed to the side
I couldn't agree more that these are
real concerns and many proponents of the
Common Core I know feel the same way so
uh
let me just try through some things I'm
gonna on the screen this is a mouse so I
just uh I'm basing my discussion on on
the map individual reading was a real
pleasure Mariza thank you
so just brought some beautiful comments
about the joy of mathematics here and
I'd like to actually just share my
personal philosophy about teaching
mathematics so forgive me I'll eat my
glasses and I'll stop reading things
sort of soon
I completely agree the dr. hacker when
he proposed in Chapter one that we
strongly focused on a path mindset when
teaching school mathematics he phrases
philosophy art theology and history all
while teaching math that is we should
teach the philosophy and the art and the
human story of mathematics as well as
its content but actually the content at
the high school level can be argued as
somewhat secondary I have never used the
quadratic formula in my personal life I
don't think I've even used it my
research life but learning that formula
wasn't the point it was the story of
quadratics it was the story but I know
from that story I know I can nut my way
from most any problem to do that subject
and I love the human story of how
mankind battled with the topic of
quadratics over millennia to discover
the surprising link between geometry and
the subject the success of literally
completing the square and while teaching
mathematics is a high school teacher
I love the mathematical stories one can
portray of the algebra and the graphing
quadratics each as being a story of
symmetry teaching high school students
of the beauty and power of symmetry to
advantage for problem solving there's so
much beauty and richness and prompt
solving learners been doing right there
in that subject the quadratic formula
itself is somewhat irrelevant in
secondary to me the ultimate goal of
education is to help people see and
consider and practice taking the road to
higher good how to develop informed
views how to consider and probe
alternate views how to analyze how you
know what you think you know and how to
be curious and also to be aware of some
great human achievements of mankind the
works of Shakespeare Greek drama and the
revelation of completing the square
learn how to appreciate art using an
intellect
accomplishments high school is really
not about content every piece of high
school math in fact most every piece of
every topic getting whittled completely
away if you're only looking for a
utilitarian use of it where was the last
time we had to compose a hiker in
everyday life whereas the last time of
being a work the castle helped you in
the problem in life so content is really
not so much the point it's all about
teaching aspects of beings and
accomplished thinking and I think math
is particularly good at teaching problem
solving and with basic life skills
thinking through challenges now I make
note saying that the skills are met and
necessarily transferable actually
possibly proves that the math or for any
subject but math certainly offers one of
many ranges of human thinking as a
worthy piece gathered one's general
thinking repertoire I think math is good
at teaching patience and problem solving
are developing conferred certain
confidence relying on your wits and
national way through challenges dealing
with false leads and false turns on the
light
dr. hacker and I each believe a common
core but we are deeply concerned about
possible implementation in particular
with a deleterious effects of this
persistent culture of testing that
doesn't seem to ever go away in
mathematics education
so let's teach algebra to and common
core's it should be a human experience a
humorous story with context and joy it
really can be a grand service or our
next generations now let's be absolutely
clear what the Common Core actually is
so I've gone through
what is the common core okay at the list
of car is list of two standards the list
of content standards they're outlining
actual pieces of mathematics it seems it
makes sense as a storyline of the
mathematics from K through 12 and a
pedagogical appropriate storyline to
kids of different ages there's actually
nothing new in the Common Core State
Standards themselves the content of the
mathematics it's just people thought
very deeply what the storyline that
makes sense and I say yay to that
however the Common Core goes further it
also says we must attend eight practice
standards eight statements of thinking
it wants us to actually attend to
thinking and I have to say yes yes yes
yes yes this is phenomenal this is a
major achievement of the Common Core
make sense of problems and persevere in
solving them reason abstractly and
quantitatively don't just you know know
the abstract interpolation Belgium earth
step back and understand what it means
in terms of number sense and so forth
construct viable arguments of reasoning
of others these are really sort of think
about arguments of mathematics model
with math makes model real-world
problems in a model mathematics itself
with mathematics use appropriate tools
don't just use calculators the sake of
cards or smartphones really think about
what tools are necessary appropriate in
mathematics I mean you can't argue
against this attend to precision now
this one misleads people it sounds like
okay we're going to compute things to
seventeen decimal places no they mean
precision of language learn how to
describe what you really mean you're
talking about
beautiful look for and make use of
structure you see an equation can you
step back from it and see maybe the
squared term is saying something I see
the structured equation is tell me
informing about a piece of mathematics
and look for an express regular
regularity repeated reasoning that is
rather do the same type of calculation
over and over and over again can you
notice that if you just take one step
back they all follow the same structure
and just solve for one general problem
instead when you gargy that's the story
of algebra right there let's be very
clear many people think the Common Core
State Standards is hundreds and hundreds
of standards
you know when I said it we can each be
personally responsible for our well
understanding of matters you can
download the Common Core State Standards
just Google Common Core State Standards
you'll get a document download it didn't
your control s or whatever to find
keywords I actually counted just 436
State Standards was formed 36 of them I
was generous state senators a good
standard number for had parts ABC our
tenets three standards so I counted four
hundred thirty six of these things 287
was from grades K through eight 149 for
high school and thirty of those hundred
forty nine twenty percent of them are
optional there's flexibility here so
Graham soared to 36 standards always
looking good
the biggest point to make is it's not a
curriculum and here's the trouble this
is this is a real danger it is very easy
to confuse state implementation of the
Common Core State Standards as in State
Standards you can find I agree really
troubling examples out there in
textbooks that simply comment or aligned
well that's that particular state
interpretation the Common Core State
Standards there are no lesson plans
there are no less details about that
lesson plans there are no uniform tests
and parallel storage systems there is no
general arm uniform system for the
nation and people feel like the
standards themselves are questions for
students to give me I'm just going to
use examples on the books as a central
theme of conversation example here are
two state standards use the properties
of exponents to interpret expressions of
exponential functions how see an
expression different way and give
meaning to us that standard number F is
a terrible number system Thoreau means
Nolan applies the binomial theorem for
the expansion of X plus y to the nth
power and connected Pascal's triangle
okay they are not questions they are the
standards by the way this one about
Pascal's triangle is an optional
standard the plus sign being is optional
so Martin area curriculum spending on
whatever state decides to do the thing
to two things to note here
I couldn't none of these standards are
actually optional and secondly they're
not written for student
sumption they're written for experts for
the teachers the quicken drivers it
doesn't mean I'm going to call it
binomial theorem let me know I'm going
to call it past in Australia gourmet
guys won't use that language so that's
an educators choice the Common Core
State standard selves to speaking to the
academic to the world dr. Hackett was
beautiful he remembers what the scary
words out there about the Common Core
State Standards and forgive me for
pulling out some of these and I feel
like a being a bit rude here but a lot
of the follow-up articles response to
book hopped on to words in particular as
the most apparent asymptote so so to
give me you did pull out a lot of words
that being bandied about is in the
Common Core State Standards um
I download the document I check it
azmuth in there no I don't know what
estimate this myself have to ask my
astronomy friends I have a sense of
astronomy work reagent angles doesn't
appear in their trinomial does not
appear in their lips auditorium does not
appear there this was a bit funny X
equation I assume the quote I could say
P is there but X equation doesn't the
word asymptote does indeed appear in the
economic or state stands I do miss that
scary word is there it's in one optional
standard one a lot of people are scared
of the word algorithm and this claim
that the Common Core is teaching a lot
of these strange algorithms that are
irrelevant to everyday life yes it's
true the word album appears five times
the Common Core State Standards grades
three through six it's the long edition
long subtraction loan modification long
division
done all the base ten so these
misconceptions we can check you for
ourselves
are they really part of common core or
they just people's interpretations the
Commerce drawl it's a very very scary
little game what's going on um I'll be
fair there are actually some terms that
people bandy about that are in the
common core so example elliptical
equations I have it as a mathematician I
know that's not in the common floor it's
a very big high-powered research topic
elliptic equations but I think it means
the word ellipse and the world lift does
appear in one optional standard so you
know you can check these things
resources playing this game and yes
there are really are some scary words
that do appear for example inverse
functions yes they are in the common
core appears five times actually trouble
so Natalie or
interesting so let's be very clear what
the common core is not a curriculum or a
no test it's people's interpretation of
the Common Core that might head that way
another thing being bounded about and I
said that seen this from several places
is that people worry about statistics
that young kids don't understand the
diversity correlation and causation and
that bad quickness don't attend to this
you know what I applaud the Common Core
they caught this one is an actual
standard please distinguish between
correlation and causation actually tend
to us to minute proofs this is a scary
one because we all have the experience I
believe of our education days that these
two column proofs and geometry a lot of
the Common Core math petitions do not do
proof that way that those were probably
invented now I don't know my story here
so forgive me I haven't checked the
facts on the origin two column proof but
I bet they're a pedagogical device to
help students to screening systemize
their thinking but that's not how
through fears a mathematician is
horrified at the idea of doing a proof
by one blob of our risk statement reason
so unnatural sterile none of that's in
the common core and the one that's the
real shocker for many educators is the
word simplify does not appear in the
common core one place which is very
scary for a lot of teachers is if I ask
you is supply route 20 I will tell you
my answers mathematician looks pretty
good to me later that is all depends on
what you want to do with it so all these
knee-jerk reactions are route 20 must be
2 root 5 not homecoming for don't just
need to knee-jerk reactions particularly
knee-jerk reactions let's be honest here
this one comes up with in trigonometry
lot 1 over root 2 you start be allowed
to write that on the page because you
can do radicals on the bottom coming for
mine just do what's in the context has a
thinking process of doing mathematics
and I'll just finish off with one final
point which I can go into much further
detail the idea of numeracy quantitative
literacy oh boy it is so in the common
core
so uh so Lynn Arthur's been actually
talked about we need quantitative skills
in a math curriculum again please check
the times of quotes that quote was 2003
many years before the common cause in
conceives
and look what we do and Bethel pent up
to we want kids to think quantitatively
and you know dr. jack is doing a
spectacular courses we want to 101
courses Madras I went through these
apples and did I find illustrative math
which is a which is group is trying to
find actual mathematical examples
relating each particular core topic
dealing with very issues that is course
content with yes I give you a list of
all the examples that deal relative
numbers estimation and context the
parents editors spatial reasoning
approximation playing with high highs
and big one we should talk about pie at
one point and I'll be my times up I'll
stop there Thank You professor hacker
okay I've just been taking some notes
James's talk and just comment on them
first of all I'm not an expert in the
Common Core and I prefer not to see I
have read all the Common Core State
Standards click rate for high school I
went through them I think at a certain
point I counted something like 700 1764
individual standards but ever since they
also do what does the tests that tests
are going to be given next year
nationwide or at least 40 plus states
and they're going to be uniform or at
least parallel tests they're being done
by Park no PRC smarter balanced is it
smart abouts
so I can margarine you know
or some tests some states for every one
test but the whole point to the Common
Core was that before the Common Core
each state did it separately and guess
what
in this is City 90% of the people high
school seniors were passing in math in
Mississippi and in Minnesota only 74
percent for why because each taste state
at its own test
common core is going to have a test and
you have I'm sorry I shouldn't take that
away those of us who are math teachers
will have to teach to the test sorry you
have to because the test results I'm not
talking about evaluating teachers in
terms of salary or even closing schools
I'm saying that states themselves will
be evaluated under Common Core results
much of Pisa does for countries today so
it doesn't matter whether we call
standards or curriculum just look at
what's going to be on my test that your
students are going to have to go through
hour after hour okay
and the failure rate is going to be
disastrous why because it's college
level almost SAT level for the Common
Core second year algebra and carefully
about the Agora
triples Pascal second year out of a
football and we're going to have one or
two things New York and Kentucky have
already had some pilots upon Common Core
type tests oh two-thirds failed the math
in those two tests next time around when
it's done with many more states left we
decided doing three fudge the scoring
system you know renormalization well
making weeks end up with two thirds
failing you're going to hear from your
legislators are not one because it's
their constituents oh yes it's going to
be white kids from the suburbs who fail
not just kids in the back roads of the
rural counties
oh no and we'll see what happens and the
question is
why why are we putting ourselves who is
a sadistic torture when we really don't
have now this math help you us with
problem solving
well Oh relax why not I could have won
not with problem solving yes with
problem solving in mathematics I'll give
you a problem that I've had to deal with
five times myself as a citizen I have
been a juror in five criminal cases
might ask why they choose me
well my kind face anyway I've been and
in each of those trials five criminal
two murders the prosecution said we will
prove through the armed a reasonable
doubt the defendant here did it we had
to use our minds to solve that problem
did they have enough proof beyond a
reasonable doubt or not I assure you
that any mathematicians in my Curie's
that Whitney were no better than the
bicycle messenger I remember Jose once
pointing something out am I saying to
him gee Jose I never thought of looking
at it that way and Jose had never even
been in a math class and by the way just
do something else because it's somebody
I know you know then Paul Wolfowitz as
he got from he was Rumsfeld's number two
in the Defense Department more than any
other single person both of us gave us
the Iraq war I knew it because I know
not the Cornell he was a math major
his father was math professor and the
finest mathematical minds when he had
his razor-sharp mind said when we go
into Baghdad everybody will cheer us in
the street and I'll adopt democracy
tomorrow look I don't even make this
claim for political science but
mathematics shouldn't
the beauty of mathematics and here when
James talked to repeated mathematics Oh
mr. t roll down my eye because yes
process beauty and it is true when we
teach the Merchant of Venice when we
teach TS Eliot's poetry when we teach
Jane Austen's novels there's a beauty
there with you convey and my challenge
to mathematics teachers and professor to
please you see a beauty in mathematics
can you convey that to your students
you've got a captive audience they can't
read you've got a chance to do and yet
that success rate I'm sorry on this is
not good of the bachelor's degrees
awarded last year only 1% for two math
majors it used to be three percent two
minutes down to one percent now
something's happening there maybe it's
because of the way the stuff you have to
teach in the textbooks that you can't
take time off and to show on the sheer
beauty of beauty of Pi well give it a
try just one last thing I think whatever
one want to get to them okay I realize
that most of us in this room are
academics we're not vocational teachers
I'm a liberal arts teacher I teach in a
liberal arts college I'm not training
people to be lawyers things like that
but we're really being sold a bill of
goods on how we have to train people for
stem stem stem get them to major in the
STEM fields so let me put something out
because once I heard this I really have
to use it all just for me
sam says them and even Starbucks
they just look behind the counter look
Oh scoffing machines that's real
high-tech stuff but you know you know
what has sold those around the world and
by the way Starbucks is all over China
and Russia too
you know what sold around the world not
the technology sure but the magic of
those words who thought of Google I know
we're method we know what Google is but
who thought of putting Google out there
for example Twitter okay you don't have
to major in math you don't have to be an
engineer what we do need okay are more
people who are poets those are poetic
words we need kids who do that but you
know they're not even going to be easy
get to college because they're going to
stumble over algebra so the future of
this country then maybe just this like
new word thing that when you think of a
fifth one to put down there that will
resound across the globe I say more
power to you
thank you now genes yes the beauty of
math the beauty in general beautiful
human that's less explored all the way
through even in teaching high school
algebra to testing I you know we are so
on the same page with this culture of
testing are it's all about getting what
questions to what questions using a
numerical ask for what question under
speed that isn't observe seems somewhat
joyless to me and I personally would not
want to participate when I was a high
school teacher I think I was a kind of a
radical high school teacher I used to
give quizzes with all the answers
supplied you know what's the height of
this tree given us the silly thing about
angles whatever while the way 4.2 meters
and then a big blank space for students
to work on what am I trying to tell my
kids they're the answers on Porter three
the thinking process behind that we
should have more that I used to get
these things called hunch percent
packages you know you have a month to do
this your job is just keep doing it
handle to me over and over and over
again surely and hundred percent oh your
husband took your month to figure it out
great it took you just a week no worries
you figure it out it's a cultural shift
weenie that's that's a tough one but I
don't think algebra two is actually to
higher barrier but issue is how we teach
the subject we teach with beauty and joy
and Wonder and humanness
so let me actually I mean this is a bad
evening record is a mess so uh mark is
gonna be somewhere I let's let's think
of things trigonometry is often themed
scary scary too scary let's think about
its human story uh what's the first
thing mankind doing sitting on the
surface I wanted where they're at where
am i what is this thing
and there are stuff like you're sitting
on horizon is me sitting on the heart
surprised and contemplating what I'm
doing you might notice the Sun rises in
the east it goes over a head a little
bit and they come to settles in the West
and probably twelve hour late 12 hours
later comes back again something like
that very crude you probably notice a
lot of perfect circle but as a first
approximation states a circle and a
natural human question would be alright
how high is the Sun at some point a lot
of day how high it is no idea how high
it is I can't get on the top of the Sun
and drop a rope down and measure it the
fact the only day I can measure is this
angle I can look up at so all I have is
the angle of elevation they've got
measure it's on a 30 degrees or
something
all right grand us the story of
trigonometry was born how do I measure
the height of stars at different angles
of elevation that's it that all thought
is there's a lot of human story here
this is Indian mathematicians call this
the gr of an angle whether this idea is
assuming union what the radius laws they
call it one great big on an
astronomically big unit one astronomical
unit to the Sun they called the GR the
angle then that took often the 800
sister in the least and was translated
from the sanskrit into the arabic zebra
or jo-jo i think it was but in arabic
they tend not to Baal of writing the
vowels is just lessons JB as the height
of the star at different angles
well then math took off in Western
Europe in the 1200 they went all down to
Madrid and translated the math books and
from from arabic into latin they saw
this jb thought there's no what word JP
is in Arabic they came up with Cheever
which means clove like a little Hobbit
up a ship which are both safely at night
why are they calling the height of star
the clover the star oh well we'll use
the Latin word for Cove finals which
then became sign so you know there's the
human story of why recall that the sign
of an angel and why that might be called
the companion to sign next question
promise for my kids okay I've drawn 30
degrees let's do census one great big
astronomical unit how high is that star
okay I've given us a problem what going
to do and eventually if someone might
have an epiphany to the walk oh look at
this it looks like it's half an
equilateral triangle ah perfect like a
triangle then in which case what must
this length be half the side of the
triangle
must be a half suddenly I've got my kids
working at the signing cosine of 30
degrees just like this this is joyous
teaching this is algebra 2 I believe
it's actually within reach of everyone
and I think you tell you in use of this
sure we can go and measure Heights of
trees or bits of rope dangling off on
from them to me is joyless that's more
joyful what an experience that everyone
had I think algebra 2 is actually within
reach of our nation I think we're
duty-bound to share that with the world
I don't think say anything too deep I
think we cluttered the curriculum let's
declutter curriculum and bring the human
story to it I will fall out
to the world actually don't see a
problem how much time do I have left I
keep rapping on 337 337 proof through
its mathematics hopeful with proof
well this scares me because just because
the same word is used in different
context as we were talking about the
same thing but the proof does come up in
jewelry cases a mathematical proof and
it scares the Dickens L a lot of people
I think of two examples for any type of
one so it's a classic example I think
Bob and Ellen Kaplan wrote about this in
the book chances are imagine there's a
town where 90% of the cabs are blue and
temperatures are purple and a crime
District passed and the eyewitness says
the cab that went away was blue so I'll
just do this so you're on eyewitness
you're in a town out of 100 cabs 19 will
be blue and 10 will be purple I think I
says all I said all right
so the lightener says I saw a purple cat
go away well they tested the eyewitness
and I'm being shown the colors blue and
purple at random she was able to
identify the correct color 80% of the
time soon making up the numbers so 82 0
times is a pretty reliable witness she's
grand well this thing about it so among
these 90 blue taxi cabs that she'll be
correct a sixth of the time so pretty
for the time should be wrong so 18 cabs
will say 18 that these are actually
purple when they're really blue and the
rest of them was at 72 if you say really
are blue of the ten actually purple ones
will say two of them I mistakenly blue
and H them actually whoops secondly no
you're right son right purple
so what could blue all right this
witness says she definitely saw a blue
cat go away she's eighty percent
reliable on these eyewitness tests what
are the chances she's actually correct
well she said blue of these 22 cases and
these are two cases so that's 34 cases I
wish I'd down elicited a blow around I
want to make it purple red purple purple
punch board convincing here so say she
said purple
8 out of 20 times who's actually correct
that it really was purple and saying
purple there's a eight and twenty six
charges among those eight examples eight
l26 that sounds like about thirty
percent to me which is only thirty
percent reliable and I believe this sort
of Bayesian thinking does happen in
court cases every now and then and
jurors biologic just do this cannot
follow this which hopeful I get the
numbers right post but that is I think a
good example that actually very matte
okay hundred percent of the math we
teach is used by somebody and no one
individual prodigies anymore probably
ignores 99.5% of it however I cannot say
which 99% I should throw out of
curriculum or stop deny people a chance
to this color point made at eloquent in
grade ten we start giving people have
options babies in grade eight that's a
hard question I think we could reach
algebra two is being a reasonable
challenge if we actually teach it with
truth Beauty context relevant meaning
humanists and joy and even polynomials
are joyful it's done in the right way I
feel that no need not obsessed with
exploding dots let's approve that story
because it really is seeing base-10
stepping back and finding a joyful
picked up mathematics book you knew and
suddenly whole portal of universal
wonder opens up and gives of a bit more
flexibility freedom even with
polynomials but don't teach attacked the
kingdom I can't I kissed divided upon a
mule I don't care about that but can
they talk about them beautifully why
gifts the notion I would say thanks
thank you
well thank you both now it's time for
questions so we'll get set up for
questions there has to be somebody that
will run the mic around we're going to
turn off the lavell ear mics we have to
turn those off to make the other mics
but but let me before we before we begin
let me let me say something that's
slightly unusual here we're going to
spend about 15 minutes or so
with questions from the audience and
then when we're done by the way you'll
have a chance to come up and ask
individual questions of the speakers I
can't help myself here I have to make an
observation
and the observation is that all three of
us here are really in some sense we're
not I mean James has been a teacher but
we're not presently teachers in schools
we're in some sense university people or
university like people and this is what
happens all the time
think about it we're talking about k-12
education here about mathematics and the
role in in in k-12 in high schools but
also in middle schools and elementary
schools Kent can you imagine having a
meeting in which we discuss some medical
practice and there wasn't a practicing
doctor anywhere in sight
can you imagine ever doing that the fact
that we're three people all of us who
are not teachers says an awful lot about
the state of education in this in this
country and and so I would like to say
that I will take questions from the
audience
but I would prefer to take questions
from k12 teachers in the audience if you
don't mind so
at least in the beginning I'd like to
hear from k-12 teachers all right I will
bring the microphone and give it a
second if you could stand up okay
I do teach six and eighth grade math so
sure what do you want
my question is to dealing with that like
what do you suggest like I think you
guys have both really great points but
what do we do we're stuck in the middle
oh sorry we were the ones stuck in
middle right now like what do you give
suggestions because that's where we are
right now I think very simply I know
you're caught because your school the
state lays down what you have to teach
and this is something that I'm freed
from at the college level but I
understand appreciate what you have to
do I would simply say as we always used
to say write your Congressman
you know this is a political question
this is not just an education question
and make your voice heard on this say
look I want more freedom to teach the
beauty of mathematics rather than the
fifth or a standard that you're
requiring me see if it could make you
boys heard if you belong to a union I
hope they'll take that up two separately
my biggest culture shock going from the
university was become a high school
teacher was just how pretty okay okay I
get excited plus I seem to have an
accent apparently so my biggest culture
shock coming from the university world
to be high school teaching was how
pranic and mentally busy a world that
was and of all professions that should
be reflecting deepening or teaching
reflecting deeply on teaching the high
school world offered next to no chance
to reflect on teaching it was it was
really shocking to me and disturbing and
I was really interested in the challenge
of how do I find the wiggle room
nonetheless get my kids to pass the
tests now I do admit that I was in the
public school
the school world which is exempt from
the state standards and state test the
time they're not actually qualified to
teach in the public school world EHD but
I had the culture was loud and clear my
algebra 2 experience with my kids was my
kids need to know this formula demeanor
dab it need these to be able to do 50 of
them in a row also do some push-ups
while you're at it so that uh so I
taught the story completing the square
nonetheless and got my kids drawing
little boxes on the sides there tests my
colleagues had no idea what these boxes
were even I tried to try talking about
it and they still answer the questions
it's the wiggle room and it's very hard
it's very exhausting and you feel like
you're alone so do write your
Congressman and blog and tweet about it
I think the power of social media is a
very strong movement in this very room
in fact of people are really are working
in concrete examples to bring joy to all
levels of math teaching and it there is
room for it it can't be done
unfortunately should we have more room I
want to speak about teaching that I did
in East Harlem here in New York City in
elementary school I taught
problem-solving how to think
mathematically and in the weeks before
the test I said to the in two weeks
before the tension I said to the teacher
you know how to teach them how to bubble
in and do a test now you do that so I
want to know what you mean about
teaching for the test because to me
teaching mathematics is teaching for the
test and the better you teach
mathematics the better the students can
handle whatever is thrown at them that
they might not have seen before so
you're talking about something that I
need you to explain because to me it's
teaching mathematics Thank You mr.
hacker
okay just very briefly what do I mean by
teaching to the test here's my best
example Princeton Review and Kaplan you
go to them you pay and they teach you
how to beat the test in fact some of the
people I talk to us coaches say you know
I can teach you to get 400 I know it's
not great but for
hundred on the SAT without knowing even
a thing about mathematics in fact it
could be a test in Bulgarian they teach
you how to beat the test
look we're professionals were teachers
we love learning my own view is I happen
to be with a far right wing on this I am
against the Common Core
I'd rather have it got rid of totally
and leave it to you in the classroom
you're a professional to teach what you
think should be taught or you think is
important and by the way if in one
school different people are teaching
different things in math classes fine
where a thousand flowers bloom you know
there isn't one thing everybody has to
know I'll be quick teaching to the test
that is a big scary one because the easy
way to interpret that okay here's the
quadratic formula let's memorize of a
sing a song to help you memorize it and
that will solve all the quadratic
formula problems that is the rotates
teachers possess and you can do that
it's joyless and it's kind of what's
expected by many parts of our culture
that that's what mathematics mean is all
about computation and getting the
answers with speed a fundamental
paradigm shift just occurred I don't
know how to make that happen other than
just we keep working out the ways we're
describing earlier but I agree I was
teaching my kids to think and I felt
confident they were passing the tests
had evidence they passed the test but
they felt the resistance because they
knew their colleagues were doing
different things they got nervous about
it so there's a lot of lot of work needs
to be done and work with parents is very
scary I haven't having an accent that
seems to develop some respects so I
think I could talk to parents that sound
like I knew what I was talking about so
they believe me and I think if I was a
ship PhD helped a lot however you know I
admit I that was in my favor with
discussing this with parents they
trusted me but that trust is very hard
one to attain I agree hi I'm a high
school student
I've taken the Common Core and I guess
now it's just a real adjustment period
well we I guess transition to the Common
Core and so I guess results will be
shaky I I think you said that only
two-thirds of students have passed
in New York or have failed it so far our
one-third and I was just wondering over
time do you think as more kids have
taken in it and as teachers have had
more time to learn how to prep kids take
it of results will improve and generally
it will be more accepted the Common Core
over but by the way I'll just say that
there's a misconception here getting
being proficient right the common the
test has four different levels and the
misconception is that that in order to
pass the test you have to be proficient
or advanced and that's not at all what's
meant here so there's basic proficient
advanced and the figures that you hear
about only 1/3 pass that are not correct
figures that's a misinterpretation of
the levels of the test but now let me
let somebody answer oh by the way please
it's a misinterpretation no they haven't
fails they're just unprofessional
ficient does not mean what you think in
English labels labels alternative labels
let's be very clear are you speaking
about engaged New York New York's
interpretation of the Common Core State
Standards if you studied in New York
okay so this is my point earlier on I
deeply worried about implementation of
states interpretations of the Common
Core and I know that the engaged New
York in particular did something it was
very disturbing to me they said okay
we're gonna implement in 2015 we'll
start with the grade 10 curriculum as
though every students gone through the K
through 9 cultural experience of that
curriculum and they haven't so I think
it's our time to make a prediction is
probably a bit of a tough challenge for
engaged in York to stay in to stay in
New York if that's the cultural
introduction to this we were told to
write advisor on this particular
curriculum and I was very nervous right
to the 2020 student as though they've
already been through it for five years
don't write the student has not been
through it yet at all so if we give it a
chance
I personally there's good hope for
course testing is always the issue I
worry about the state of testing if it's
testing again there's going to do
anything but they're trying to be clever
in the test not asked us what questions
anymore they're asking why and thinking
questions or you know here's an algebra
problem draw a picture that best
interprets how you might go about
solving it not give you the actual
equation which of these you know so
they're trying to try to be more tense
about the tests
hopefully they'll have a good success
with that wonderful yes circuits I'm
actually asking a question on behalf of
somebody online
Daniel Finkel he asks let's suppose that
Andrew hackers proposal which is to
abolish standards
I'd say that's a summary of the proposal
is executed and we polish all standards
what might be the consequences of that
the consequences of abolishing standards
first of all look what has to happen
with the Common Core one size fits all
now currently almost half our students
don't go on after college you know they
have to high school they just finished
high school don't go further many try
college and don't finish only about a
third of Americans finish college now
what are we going to do for this non
academic two-thirds we're going to have
the Common Core Standards college and
career-ready segue into one thing and
we're going to make them both - Pascal's
triangle and Pythagoras triples no my
answer is if you get rid of it will be
have much more freedom in tailoring
education for various levels of students
and I don't mean dumb versus smart I
mean not everybody's going to go get
Caltech they're going to people who be
UPS drivers it's a non you honorable job
but why demand Pythagorean triples
Oh
the question was abolishing the
standards um so I can't help it
Pythagorean triples are not in the
common core was an example of one super
standard I personally believe that
actually PI tag me triple is a beautiful
storyline look at the clay tablets in
3,000 years ago were those Babylonians
whose listing basically socially packed
by my finger triples curious question
why what delighted them about if there's
something you delightful about those
things young kids can play with it look
at a multiplication table you can
actually even look at to that numbers on
the diagonal you actually generate a
whole bunch of Pythagorean triples in a
basic ten by ten more vacation table
there's a great mystery of kids to play
with
alright Pascal's triangle optional
standard not part of it comical and if
you wanna play with equesticles try and
with a lot of fun too if we let go of
the standards well I guess where do we
let go I mean do we want some
commonality that that kids should
release to grade 8 mathematics and know
about fundamental basic arithmetic or
not
why does later we go I don't know where
that line is and I guess my argument is
I have no trouble with the bulk of the
content and what's typically deemed
algebra 2 if it's taught in a joyous way
and I believe it can be and just by and
large isn't and so I would say maybe
general standards
I'd be scheduling ago all of them
personally hi mmm um I am a high school
math teacher in the South Bronx and my
biggest concern with the idea of not
making higher level math mandatory is
that there's already an achievement gap
in this country and my students are
already having lots of doors shut on
them and I think by saying okay only
those who can learn math are going to be
the ones to learn it that achievement
gap is just going to get larger and so
my question to you is how if we go with
this and get rid of those standards are
we going to prevent our students who are
already at a disadvantage from
continuing to get doors closed on them
[Music]
I'm really glad that question was asked
because it's a basic American question
back in some decaying trailer park
in rural Arkansas or somewhere I don't
say in the South Bronx with let's say
South Brooklyn knows out Brooklyn is
fancy
but anyway somewhere there is a kid
being brought up in a really grungy home
you know things like that happen
who has the makings of being an
astrophysicist yes there is such a child
now the question is how do we discover
that child do we do it by making
everybody 100% including the poets and
including the dancers make everybody go
through a full mathematics sequence so
we find that one person in the trailer
park who should be encouraged somehow
you better work out the probabilities
for this on me the price were paying by
making a hundred percent do something so
that one fraction of one percent will be
discovered maybe there's a better way to
discover in the trailer park that kid
may be at the age of five who has a
certain light to them a certain talent
to them age five and discover them and
whack them along to astrophysics but
don't put it on everybody including the
person who wants to be an honorable UPS
driver but needs a high school diploma
for it
gosh um don't put on everybody okay so
if what's it that's with with where's
the line do we have this choice in grade
7 grade 8 - people would self-identify
that I'm going to go into Chris doesn't
need math there call Stoppard's when I'm
12 I don't know how to make that call I
know how to put that in the system where
people make that call
and I feel like it's a fall school
because as I said let's teach math like
half as you as you argue in your first
chapter it's beautiful it's teach with
philosophy art history theology the full
bit
let's reach the humanists as much as the
scientists and learn as much as the
mathematicians in our young audiences I
believe we can do it I believe there's a
really joyous Christian to be had there
and I don't think concepts of algebra to
the in the standard curriculum are out
of reach for majority of people I think
it's worth striving for that and I don't
think it's just ludicrous to say it must
have a go at it
you know it's the culture of how we do
it we're gonna have a culture where
teachers can thrive and test it with
their human cells you know I've seen
certainly school districts where the
district supervisor says everyone needs
to be on page children 17 by next
Thursday - which Casey muscles give the
kids the textbook - the reason cells and
we'll see you on Thursday
it's joyless that's that's not how the
human mind works as a Gannett messy
process is learning lots of back and
forth we can't be in uniform sync with
SDSU just don't expect teachers to be in
sync across the whole graders but
there's not the human experience every
class is a conversation so let's make
teaching math a conversation and yes I
think it's fair enough to have like
ideas a way should be after a year how
you get to that at the end of the year
it's up to you as a teacher let's trust
teachers I don't
thank you both
before we close let me let me remind you
that there will be a book table they
here with books from both speakers on
sale over here and also that you're
welcome to come up and ask questions as
well after after we've closed I'd like
to close since I've already mentioned
woody Dudley here with the final words
of his essay is mathematics necessary
which is which is worth reading because
I think in a way it intersects with a
lot of the comments that were made
tonight by both speakers but it also is
slightly different so he finishes his
essay with these words what's
mathematics educate what what
mathematics education is for is not for
jobs it is to teach the race to reason
it does not heaven those always succeed
but it is the best method that we have
it is not the only road to the goal but
there is none better
furthermore it is worth teaching where I
give in to hyperbole I would say that
mathematics is the most glorious
creation of the human intellect but I am
not given to hyperbole so I will not say
that however when I am before the bar of
judgement heavenly or otherwise and
asked to justify my life I will draw
myself up proudly and say I was one of
the stewards of mathematics and it came
to no harm in my care I will not say I
help people get jobs thank you very much
[Applause]